quand quelqu'un arrive pour la première
fois les seules questions à lui poser
sont as-tu faim as-tu sommeil veux-tu te
laver
viens on t'attendait
mes amis croyez-moi je comprends votre
désarroi j'étais à vos côtés au front
résistant contre l'envahisseur mais nous
battons contre la famille
contre la dictature
[Musique]
vous allez devoir changer d'identité
Abbé Pierre ça vous va
pour Abbé Pierre je t'ai à vos côtés sur
les bords de l'Assemblée
[Musique]
le froid mes amis au secours une femme
vient de mourir geler sur le trottoir en
plein Paris elle s'est rassure elle le
papier par lequel on l'avait expulsé
on a appelé la voix de son voix on m'a
célébré on m'a applaudi
on m'a contesté on m'a trahi
parlementaires
[Musique]
les gens ils vont être moins en moins la
charité la bienveillance
[Musique]
c'est fini
je me suis souvent trompé
mais Maxence seulement
écouté
[Musique]
vous rendez compte
on a construit tout ça